hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur redstone update
1.5 minecraft vorstellungen was ist neu
alle änderungen werden nun von mir
zusammengefasst und ich würde sagen ich
fange direkt an nach dem intro
ja ihr seht ihr schon was ich hier so
alles aufgebaut habe und zwar saß ich
gerade von 10 uhr bis jetzt gerade 13
uhr 30 hier dran das alles aufzubauen
und ich habe hier auch nebenbei eine
komplette text datei offen die geht
genau fünf seiten alle möglichen
neuerungen ich glaube es ist das größte
update was die hier raus gebracht haben
bzw das komplexeste weil echt eine menge
menge redstone sachen dazugekommen sind
also wenn ihr wirklich über alles
bescheid wissen wollt dann guckt euch
das video komplett an und ich würde mich
echt freuen wenn ihr eine positive
bewertung abgibt bzw einfach einen
daumen hoch gibt weil das zeigt mir dass
euch das ganze gefällt und dass sich
eventuell immer zu den großen updates
sondern lange vorstellung machen soll
und einfach ich sag jetzt drei bis vier
stunden hier dran und das wird mich echt
total freuen
so dann würde ich sagen wir auch direkt
am gerät im hintergrund alle sachen habe
ich schon aufgebaut die meisten sachen
sind echt redstone sachen die die schon
länger auf einem kanal sind und mich
schon länger abonniert haben wissen dass
ich nicht zu der allergrößte redstone
profi bin hat mich aber versucht mal ein
bisschen damit auseinanderzusetzen und
mich habe ich glaube ich habe das ganz
gut hingekriegt und ich würde sagen ich
fange jetzt mal hier an in dem kleinen
staat häuschen und wir fangen sofort mit
den allgemeinen änderungen an denn ich
hab das alles ein bisschen sortiert und
zwar nach warten euch schon mal ganz
kurz ich habe paar ober punkte die ober
punkte sind allgemeine änderungen dann
die spielmechanik dann vom public und
items und dann die mobs bzw npcs und
dann noch eine welt generierung das
größte beziehungsweise größe bestandteil
wird blöcke und items sein weil das
einfach eine menge ist was er dazu
gekommen ist an redstone sachen die sie
hat ja hier schon alles da zum beispiel
dieser tnt loren oder hier die redstone
komparatoren oder komparatoren oder
irgend sowas und ich würde sagen ich
fange direkt mal nicht möchte das ganze
allerdings bei nacht lassen times 20.000
da das bei nacht alles ein bisschen
geiler aussieht fällig und die ab also
erstmal allgemeine änderungen das licht
wurde verbessert und zwar wenn ich jetzt
irgendwelche fackeln haben wisst ihr
könnt ihr in allen im menü einstellen ob
ihres muts lightning haben wollt also
das war keine änderungen bestehen und
das alles so langsam aufhört oder dass
ihr das so direkt wollt das ist jetzt
einfach so dass es immer so direkt so
ist ihr könnt das natürlich immer noch
umstellen aber das ist auf jeden fall
performance unlustiger also zieht nicht
mehr so viele fps wenn ihr das da
normal so hat wie ich das jetzt gerade
habe und was auch der fall ist wenn ihr
zum beispiel redstone mattern habt also
sonst wäre sie relativ dunkel und die
machen ja sonst mehr sonnenlicht
allerdings machen die nach dahin jetzt
mehr licht als nach hinten das sieht man
dem kleinen raum jetzt relativ schlecht
aber ich denke ihr wisst was ich meine
genau das gleiche ist auch bei höfen der
fall oder hält bei diesen kürbis hat er
das geht halt nur noch in diese richtung
und hinten ist das nicht mehr so eine
große starke beleuchtung außerdem wurden
nun die block texturen in einzelne
dateien aufgeteilt und dadurch können
zum beispiel texturen für block und
items nun auch animiert werden wie zum
beispiel das wenn man eine kiste öffnet
das dann irgendwie so blasen da
rauskommen oder staub oder in wissen was
können und action texturen pack
hersteller adobe swatch hat können nun
alles selber machen ich kenne mich damit
natürlich nicht so aus aber die texte
und pack erstellt aber ich denke
hannibal lisa janina et cetera die
wissen schon was sie damit anfangen
können außerdem gibt es nun verbesserte
menü beziehungsweise
einstellungsmöglichkeiten zum beispiel
der button für textur pack optionen
hearings hier seht ihr ist gar nichts
mehr sondern der ist unter option
texturen pakete dann seht ihr hier meine
ganzen text texture pack gibt es hier
eine datenerhebung einstellung wie das
alles hier so aufgebaut dass etc es gibt
halt viel viel mehr möglichkeiten ihr
seht doch hier die ganzen höhen et
cetera dies im multiplayer gibt das ist
alles besser aufgeteilt und wenn ich in
der welt drin bin kann ich nur noch ohne
ob die feine den optionen texturen
pakete einfach mal ein anderes text
auswählen wie zb das von dem valentine's
day da seht ihr jetzt keine großen
änderungen weil das halt so ein bisschen
verändert wurde aber ich kann es jetzt
alles auch direkt während des spiels
verändern
sonstiges ist noch dass die
sprachdateien die man eventuell für
einige adventure maps brauchte
beziehungsweise auch durch texturen
pakete oder moz wie zum beispiel matt
muss hinzugefügt werden an einigen
leuten wird das bestimmten begriff sein
dass es eine modifikation defense
sounds hinzu wenn ihr zum beispiel in
schwerte macht das so klingen oder wenn
ihr sterbt macht das krank oder
irgendwie sowas also so ganz
interessante sachen die können im
hintergrund ohne haupt update
heruntergeladen werden kommen wir nun
zur spielmechanik und zwar gibt es ein
scoreboard also ich werde jetzt erst mal
ein paar sachen sagen dass dort jetzt
vielleicht noch 30 sekunden bis ich euch
hier ein paar sachen zeige hier zum
beispiel das unbedingt von altem stil
zum beispiel wenn die socken sammlung
oder so das werde ich euch später gleich
alles zeigen aber ich rede jetzt erst
mal ganz kurz und zwar ist das letzte
was ihr euch etwas sagen wollte das
scoreboard ihr könnt mich einfach so
scoreboard eingeben im multiplayer jetzt
in listings geht das natürlich nicht
syntax kennen wahrscheinlich einige
leute aus dem taschenrechner ist eine
funktion bzw eine art von arrow dies
gibt es gibt dann auch alle möglichen
anderen errors aber der scoreboard ist
als aufgebaut dass ihr diese scoreboard
da hat dann steht der objectives player
teams das ist auf deutsch ziel spieler
und team und das wird halt verwendet
diese scoreboard und den punktestand in
bestimmten kategorien anzuzeigen also zb
die anzahl von toten getöteten npcs oder
spielern und leben werden und angezeigt
die punktestände können zum beispiel mit
einem command blog verändert werden wenn
man zum beispiel wieder auf null gesetzt
werden will dass es dann im multiplayer
so und es gibt auch verschiedene farben
für verschiedene teams dabei ist wenn
das ganze jetzt funktionieren würde da
ich ja nicht multipel geht das nicht
da das ganze wenn das funktionieren
würde würde dir einfach hier wie wenn
ich shift gedrückt halten würde kennt ja
aus dem multiplayer dass ihr dann sehen
welche leute auf dem server sind es
fängt gerade anzuschneiden das ja auch
ganz schön dort aber mal ganz kurz aus
da stört ein bisschen ja perfekt ganze
zeit schneit es nicht und wenn die
aufnahme schneider dann klickt ihr das
halt so angezeigt lieber shift welche
spieler auf dem server sind dann seht
ihr so das
scoreboard sage ich mal welche
punktestände es gibt und ihr könnt das
übrigens auch an allen orten anzeigen
lassen also egal wo ihr gerade
multiplayer seit und nun kommen wir zu
den sachen die ich euch zeigen wollte
und zwar ist gibt es ein verbessertes
umbenennen von items und blöcken und
zwar gespannte mops wenn ich zum
beispiel hier habe ich rüdiger und die
habe ich 2 der schwaben umbenannt wenn
ich zum beispiel den rüdiger nehmen und
den hierhin setzte dann sehe ich
natürlich sehr ruhiger oder wenn ich
hier spyder schwein nehmen und das dahin
sehr ja okay ich habe jetzt warte ich
mal ganz kurz ihre psag dann steht das
beider schwein drüber das ganze wird in
einem umkreis von fünf blöcken angezeigt
das heißt wenn ich jetzt dann sehe ich
die nicht mehr so sich dann wieder das
ist der rüdiger und dass es dort spiels
beide schwellen solchen immer ganz
kurzen diamant schwert und tötete weil
er nicht das eben hier noch alles
versaut ihr klein so rüdiger tod und ja
wenn ich zum beispiel dann von zwei der
schweiz getötet worden wäre wenn ich
nicht im creative mord gewesen wäre das
durchaus der fall sein können da ich
nicht so der bvb profi bin dann wird im
chat auch angezeigt konkreter wurde
durch zwei das schwein getötet das ist
natürlich sehr witzig wenn man zum
beispiel eine spinne sich selbst nennt
einfach sich selbst dann steht im chat
kontraste wurde durch sich selbst
getötet riesen kurz contractor wurde
durch eine riesenchance getötet sehr
witzig ich merke schon ihr seid alle
herzlich am lachen ich zeige euch jetzt
aber mal ganz gut funktioniert und zwar
kann ich mir einfach ein spot zum
beispiel von einem schweigenden
legte ziehen amboss rheinländer hat
jetzt hier einfach mal oma geben das
dann habe ich die roma und den kann ich
dann einfach spawn und dann das gleiche
kann man auch mit kisten machen also
wenn ich eine kiste nehmen so kann ich
auch in die kiste reinpacken kann das
ganze dann porno sammlung nennen dann
habe ich hier die porno sammlung und
dann wenn ich die kiste hier dann zum
beispiel hinsetzte seht ihr hier bei der
planung sammlung und das ist halt sehr
sehr gut für die ganzen kisten
sortierung man ganz kurz daran weil dann
könnt ihr zum beispiel über kingston
nicht mehr nur schilder darüber machen
können die kids gleich benennen ist
natürlich doof was immer es kostet aber
im creative ist das wahrscheinlich sehr
gut und dann seht ihr oben wichtigste
items oder einfach hier zum beispiel
items von denjenigen von crafter items
von um gespielt dann hat weiß jeder hat
jeder sein eigenes und jeder weiß wem
welche sachen gehören finde ich auf
jeden fall sehr sehr sehr sehr cool
es gibt nun auch ein besser ein
verbessertes inventaren management dazu
muss ich erst mal ein paar blöcke wollen
nämlich dass ein paar diamant blöcke zum
beispiel und dann nehme ich mal so ein
paar hier also ein blöcken die blöcke
und sagt ich gehe mal ganz kurz ein game
zu null weil ich finde damit kann man
das besser zeigen
und zwar wenn man doppelklick auf ein
item macht dann fühlt man den stapel so
weit wie möglich auf das eis wenn ich
jetzt hier die ganz sicher so ein
bisschen verteile und ich mache da
doppelklick darauf dann habe ich die
wieder alle zusammen in einem stapel
wenn ich davon natürlich zwei stapel
habt dann geht das natürlich auch aber
der staffel geht dann nur so voll wie es
wirklich geht also der geht da nicht
irgendwie 64 ist 16 und 64 blöcke wenn
ich einen item stapel habe und einfach
linksklick also erst mal nämlich den so
und macht dann links fällt dann verteilt
er die hier in gleich große blöcke 110
jetzt habe ich hier zum beispiel noch
eine daran den takt an hierhin so das
geht dann natürlich nicht mehr da macht
jeder doppelklick dann habe ich wieder
alle und was ich auch sehr witzig finde
warte so jetzt hab ich jetzt seht ihr
hier jetzt eine null warte so da ist
null bei dem blog den ich garten der
hand halte leider hat war einfach der
fall weil ich die beiden jetzt
aufgeteilt war und hier habe ich dann
natürlich nichts mit es habe ich hier
zum beispiel 32 ist ganz gut wenn man
sich zum beispiel hier einfach mal alles
voll mit acht betten machen will und
dann jede machtblöcke geben will zum
beispiel im multiplayer finde ich sehr
sehr cool wenn ich den nehme und dann
rechts weg mache dann verteile ich auf
jeden slot einen gegenstand das heißt
ich habe danach hier alles voll mit die
haben an blöcken so sehr cool macht ihre
doppelte dann habe ich wieder alle hier
bin ich cool inventar druck und gerade
ein block in der hand halte also wartet
somit in der hand halte sondern einfach
nur drauf bin und schmeiße ich den weg
und wenn ich dabei auch noch steuerung
gedrückt halte dann schmeiß ich das
ganze steckt auch sehr cool
und wenn ich rechts weg zum beispiel auf
dem rüstungs teil mache was ich in der
schnellauswahl habe dafür gehe ich mal
wieder in den games 1
da das blut so ich möchte mir ganz
kurzen müll weil ich brauche ich nicht
mehr sagen wie ich habe jetzt hier eine
japanisch und macht deutlich dass hier
das hier unten ist übrigens die
schnellwahl leiste wenn ihr das nicht
willst oder rechts neigt dann so ich bin
fertig mord deswegen habe ich das wieder
hier drin aber dann habe ich so habe ich
das angezogen survival mode wetters dann
ist natürlich dementsprechend weg so ich
komme ganz kurz meiner datei wieder
runter weil es beginnt eine neue seite
es wurden außerdem auch neue befehle
hinzugefügt und wie zb der test vor
befehl ich gebe zum beispiel test vor
einem sind natürlich sehr wenig der
funktioniert nur bei comand blöcken das
heißt ich kann das jetzt so zwar
eingeben wartet mal so test vor
dann sehe ich test vor ist nur bei
kommando blöcke mit analogausgang
nutzbar also konnte ich nicht rückwärts
springen
so weil der baum ist auch so bin ich so
groß war okay wenn ich bin sehr groß
so also wo wir stehen genauer dieser
test vor wie viel der prüft ob ein
spieler im spiel ist oder eine bestimmte
bedingungen erfüllt ich kann zum
beispiel ein geben da gibt es das ihr
test vor da müsste zum beispiel wie zum
beispiel eigentlich gerade in dem an dem
spiel drin ist und dann könnt ihr noch
eine bestimmte zusatzinformationen an
geben stellt jetzt mal einfach so da zb
xyz ist ja im spiel ist ja gerade
gestorben hat er gerade in diamant
schwert irgendwie sowas und wenn das
dann funktioniert oder wenn das stimmt
oder wenn das nicht stimmt dann gibt das
einen signal an einen red dot com parat
voraus dazu komme ich allerdings später
noch das ist dieser block dort ist recht
kompliziert das ganze zu erklären habe
ich mich allerdings ein bisschen noch
eingearbeitet und ich hoffe ihr wisst
das zu schätzen darum hoch wenn ihr das
cool findet
also dass dieser test vor befehl und
dann kommen jetzt den letzten sachen wo
ich nix zeigen kann und zwar sonstiges
bei denen bei der spielmechanik es gibt
verbesserte todesmeldungen die behalten
die wir inhalten und nehme ich den todes
grund den namen des spielers und des
items für den tod das für den total
zuständig also konkreter wurde von
ungespielt mit bloßer faust getötet wird
natürlich nicht passieren da ich ja
total der profi bvbb
muss ja noch richtig wussten ja und im
creative mord können ob es nun auch aus
entfernung von fünf blöcken geschlagen
werden das habt ihr glaube ich vorhin
schon einer spyder schwimmen gesehen
wenn nicht kann ich euch das mal ganz
kurz die nicht mehr das nicht immer
zeigen naja ich glaube wir fest dass die
macht komme nichts sonst wir sind ja
nicht ohne grund
so ich kann jetzt auch von weiter weg
statt da kann ich mir diese ein bisschen
vom hals halten wenn da zum beispiel
creepers und oder so also ich denke ihr
wisst was ich meine und nun kommen wir
endlich zu den blöcken und items darauf
wo er alle gewartet haben jetzt geht das
video richtig los und zwar wurde ein
weblog hinzugefügt und findet ihr hier
unter redstone in das allgemeine netz
und sachen obwohl ich gar nicht sagen
hier ist der redstone blog das ist eine
art bewegliches redstone signal habe ich
das gekaufte cd gekauft bzw beweglichen
redstone quelle es gibt einen red dieser
blog gibt ein redstone signal ab und der
kann mit kolben zum beispiel auch
verschoben werden ihr seht ihr habe ich
ein redstone da habe ich eine rolle
achte auf die redstone lampe wenn ich
ihr den schalter drücken da die geht
jetzt nämlich anwalt dieser block leitet
nun ein signal dahin das ist quasi
sowieso im redstone puck sag ich mal nur
halt als block also finde ich auf jeden
fall sehr sehr cool diesem letzten block
weil man damit halt dinge besser planen
kann zum beispiel wenn man erfahren hat
und die ist
quasi
verkabelt mit ganz viel redstone sachen
und man will das dann leeren dann drückt
man einfach in schaltern und väter sohn
letzten block aus und dann anstatt im
redstone blog anstatt dieser rätsel und
lampen zum beispiel irgendwie und
richter oder so die ganzen items ländern
eingeführte hört richtig druck wir mit
sachen die da hatte die ich noch gar nie
erklärt habe also wartet richter findet
ihr dort da komme ich gleich dazu also
das ist der appstore blog wann gibt es
auf gewichtete druckplatten zwar eine
kiste mit paar diamant blöcken da gibt
es nämlich also die werden zum
detektieren von items die darauf liegt
benutzt detektieren ist fachjargon
fachjargon heißt glaube ich detektieren
heißt du was sie feststellen einfach
also es wird festgestellt klargestellt
wird geschaut irgendwie sowas um euch
das mädchen zu erklären und die
signalstärke also habe ich ein paar
vergesse ich weiß gar nicht womit das
rad verbesserbar das ähnlich sehen aber
ich bin perfektionist
ich weiß gar nicht ob das eine gute
eigenschaft ist ob nun perfektionist ist
oder nicht aber egal die signalstärke
wert nämlich die steigt mit der anzahl
der items die da drauf liegen also die
steigt linear linear heißt so was wie
gleichmäßig muss er ja auch die jüngeren
zuschauer denken ja dass ein bisschen
erklären und zwar die goldene
druckplatte ist die leichte druckplatte
findet ihr auch hier ist auch gewichtete
druckplatte leichtgewichte druckplatte
schwer dies die holden das leicht die
silberne ist schwer bzw wenn ich hier da
wird das maximale signal bei 60 alte
muss schon ausgelöst wir drauflegen und
hier erst bei 600 das heißt wenn ich
hier in speck drauflegen so steuerung
kommt ja das denkt wegschmeißt wird das
signal kompletter hingeleitet wenn ich
allerdings das gleiche ich hier mache da
geht das nobis da also das funktioniert
nicht gleichmäßig ihr seht schon was ich
damit meine ungefähr also wenn man zum
beispiel items drauflegen sollen das
dann erst was geleitet werden soll oder
in wieso ich glaube ihr wisst was ich
damit meine dann kommen wir nun zum
tageslicht sensor und der gibt nämlich
ein signal mit einer von der tageszeit
abhängigen signalstärke hat das heißt
wir haben jetzt grad tag das heißt die
red sox beleuchtet wenn ich allerdings
times 20.000 machte auf die website
lampe die ist jetzt nämlich auswahl ist
es nacht und kein licht und der tages
sensor kommt daher gerade mal gar nicht
zum einsatz kommen wir nun zum retter
und ruhe die gibt beim öffnen ein signal
aus das von der anzahl der spieler die
hineingucken abhängt das heißt wenn ich
so eine kiste multiplayer stehen habe
und nur einen typ kopf rein und wird zum
beispiel ein signal not einen block
weiter geleitet dann allerdings 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 spiele reingucken wird das
signal neuen blöcke weitergeleitet also
nur in red storm blöcke daneben sind und
das signal wird auch durch blöcke unter
der truhe weitergeleitet aber nicht
hinter ihr das heißt hier hinter kann
wird kein signal weitergeleitet können
wir mal so ganz gut zeigen und zwar wenn
ich jetzt rein gucke ich sehe dass da
hinten kommt kein signal aber hier
rechts seht ihr dass dieser redstone
blog hier am leuchtenden stationieren
redstone lampe und ja also wenn er was
darunter ist dann wird das signal auch
weitergeleitet also wenn er darunter zb
letzteres wegen so was
sie können direkt neben normalen ton
platziert werden das sorgt dann auch für
ein effektiveres lagersystem das heißt
sie kann man direkt wirklich
nebeneinander platzieren so wartet in
richmond über können wieder wegschmeißen
hier so und nun kommen wir zu den
rettern komparatoren die ich ja vorhin
schon angesprochen habe ich musste
gerade wieder bei der seite ein bisschen
kurz unter sap kurs wieder so tut mir
leid das ist man machen muss aber es
sind wirklich eine menge sachen die ihr
zugefügt wurde
der ähnelt eigentlich einem redstone
repeater besitzt aber 2 1 gegen mir also
letzten bieter hatte eigentlich nur so
einen eingang war der h2 und ich möchte
als eigentlich gar nicht so viel aus dem
wickie zu sagen was ich mir davon
abgeschrieben habe das sind wir raus
geschrieben informiert habe sondern ich
möchte euch das einfach mal selber
zeigen welch ein paar amerikanische
youtuber angeguckt haben die das
reviewed haben unbekanntere youtube
erkennt jetzt nicht die namen das camper
xx oder sowas die haben das so ein
bisschen auf englisch erklärt habe ich
versucht ein bisschen selber
beizubringen und ich versuche ich das
jetzt selber mal ganz kurz zu zeigen
also ihr seht ihr zum beispiel ich habe
hier eine quelle wenn ich die ausmachte
passiert gar nichts ein bisschen
letztere so jetzt ist das natürlich
beleuchtet ich sehe auch dass das damals
beleuchtet ist also hier kommt ein 3er
signal rein der verarbeitet das hier
dazu dass das ist erstmal egal wer das
die red storm repeater hier
angeschrieben wurde ich habe einfach
hingesetzt war keiner wusste was ich
hier hin bauen sollte also lasst euch
davon nicht irritieren
ganz entgegen dem mikro gestalten weiß
gar nicht warum aber wenn ich dann zum
beispiel hier sollen schalter drücken
dann wird das ganze ab gekappt weil das
signal hier ist jetzt weniger als das
hier so also das sind zwei wenn ich das
hier drücke dann ist es egal weil das
sind jetzt beides 3 oder das wir sind
drei und das sind drei wenn ich jetzt
allerdings dass hier drücke das ist auch
egal also wenn das hier mehr ist bzw
genau gleich viel wie hier wie dieser
eingang dann ist das egal weil dann geht
da trotzdem weiter das kann ich jetzt
hier machen kann ich hier machen kann
ich auch die alle drei so machen wenn
ich allerdings sollte die zeit das mal
hier das noch aktiviert habe dann sind
das zwei das heißt das je weniger das
heißt das hier ist mehr das jetzt sagen
wir mal signal asb mehr als signal b
dann kommt das nicht durch und ja also
dann gibt es noch diese funktion dass
wir nicht dass ihr hoch mache und hier
zum beispiel eindrücke passiert gar nix
wenn ich hier zum beispiel zwei drücke
passiert gar nichts wenn ich drei drücke
passiert also vier obst ich mich hier
raus den fatalen als wenn ich zwei drei
brücke passiert nix aber wenn ich vier
drücken da ist das 4 4 4 1 2 3 4 -
dieser drei - diese drei sind 1 also 4 -
preisen 1 also alle die es in der schule
nicht könnten 4 -30 1 das heißt einer
von denen hier wird aktiviert wenn ich
hier noch einen drauf drücken
dann habe ich zwei also
4553 sind natürlich wie jedes kind in
der schule lernt 17 2 sodann kann ich
hier noch ein letzter links umsätzen
noch einen schalter kann nicht nur wenn
ich den hier dann drücke dann sind jetzt
dementsprechend 3 also 46 33 und di
lorenzo wird aktiviert dann wieder nicht
also etwas für redstone profis die sich
damit auskennen ich habe es verstanden
aber ich weiß nicht was ich damit
anfangen soll also ich hoffe ich konnte
euch das einfach ein bisschen näher
bringen diesem letzten komparatoren
kommen wir nun zur aktivierung schiene
die kampa redstone signal aktiviert bzw
deaktiviert werden das seht ihr hier da
ist mir jetzt ein vampir jetzt ist
deaktiviert die schiene stelle ich mal
wieder hin so jetzt ist er aktiviert ihr
seht das dass es diese schiene findet
ihr hier und habe förderung hier ist die
aktivierung schiene
die gibt das redstone signal an loren
weiter die über die schiene fahren also
dass diese loris nun aufgeladen längste
diesel ohren sind mich noch nicht
aufgeladen sondern das ganze
funktioniert zurzeit nur für tnt loren
und wenn ich dann dehnt eloro drauf
gesetzt hätte leuten
dann wäre die welt nicht mehr so schön
also dann wollte ich ja nicht zeigen
also da wenn eine tnt lore drüber fährt
dann explodiert die halt und dazu kommen
später noch mal welche ihr steht schon
eine tnt lotter schnee doch das stört
mich und naja kommen wir nun zum
trichter auch eine sehr sehr geil
erneuerung finde ich sehr sehr gut auch
für ihn welche farbigen sachen beziehen
wie monster fallen er kann items
austrian redstone trichtern öfen
baustellen spender und drop an
leuchtfeuern güter loren und trichter
loren entnehmen dieser tritt dann nimmt
dann diese items auf diejenigen
hineingeworfen werden und er kann mit
hilfe von redstone aktiviert bzw
deaktiviert werden das heißt ein signal
hin kommt oder nicht weil ich jetzt
nicht aufgebaut und wissen was ich damit
meine aber wenn ich zum beispiel hier
wieder vorbereitet natürlich paar
diamanten nehme und hier zum beispiel
jetzt einen rein schmeißer dann ist ja
ein diamant doktorin der hat fünf plätze
kann also 56 aufnehmen wenn nicht einer
gegen werfe dann ist das egal also wenn
ihr einen trichter kennt kennt die kate
allen trifft aber es klappt eigentlich
und ihr wart gegen dann geht das
natürlich nicht wenn man da was reingeht
dann kommt das unten wieder raus hier
ist das nicht so dass wirklich lagert
das geht nämlich nur unten raus wenn man
da eine kiste hat das heißt ich weiß
eben was rein gelegt dass ich da ganz
schnell drauf gewartet ich kann mich
auch einfach mal hier hinstellen wenn
ich da was rein werfen ganz schnell
drauf drückt dann seht ihr denn der
block war ganz kurz hier drin so ich
zeige es euch noch mal ganz schnell der
war ganz kurze drin jetzt habe ich jetzt
zum beispiel steckt drin und das geht
dann ganz langsam alles runter er
bekennt dass von dem trichter wenn ihr
einen großen trichter zwei liter wasser
zum beispiel reinfeldt dann geht das
natürlich nicht komplett durch wenn das
solle sonst linda wer mit offenem boden
und auf einer decke sondern das geht
langsam durch und das ist genau hier der
fall und in der christliche kommen und
langsam und langsam diese ganzen jammern
blöcke an sie meinte ich das jetzt
eigentlich mit dem bob falle
beziehungsweise der fan fragt ihr euch
ganz einfach wenn ich eine farm ab und
die ganzen anderen feldern durch einen
wasserstrahl hier runter gespielt habt
ihr hier diesen trichter bekommen dann
diese items rein fallen einander rein
und trifft man sich dann ganz langsam in
der kiste also wir müssen das dann nicht
selber die ganze zeit zu organisieren
und abholen und alles also trifft auf
jeden fall eine sehr coole neuerung
gegenteil vom trichter bzw fast das
gleiche wie spencer sind die dropper die
werfen alle items aus ohne diese zu
benutzen also die ihr da rein gelegt
habt
feilschens eimer als was er einmal war
einmal et cetera die werden nicht
geschossen beziehungsweise reimer werden
nicht aktiviert das ist halt das
gegenteil zumindest besser und er kann
auch alle sechs richtungen ausgerichtet
werden also kann auch nach unten oben
links rechts oben hinten vorne kann die
items ausschütten und der kann halt auch
items im behälter vor ihm platzieren das
heißt wenn ich erzähle paar diamant
blogger nehmen fakir welche drauf habe
ich hier nicht geschadet ich habe hier
warten scripts und schalter so parteien
hinter so damit bakterien diamant
blockhaus etc oder wenn ich da zum
beispiel jetzt einfach mal so ein
wassereimer nehme den der agentur wada
der damals mal so bzw das fenster ist es
so dass die dann einfach
das war dann wirklich was herauskommt
ist natürlich hat natürlich auch seine
vorteile aber wenn man einfach das
altern haben wir was da drin ist dann
macht man das dann natürlich einfach mit
einem dropper das gleiche funktioniert
da ist schnee ich hasse schnee munro er
das gleiche funktioniert auch wenn ich
zum beispiel hier habe ich den zweck der
mann böcke drin da kann ich diese sachen
erstmal gerne lagern so
und hier in der kisters gar nichts und
wenn ich dann hier einfach drauf drückt
dann kommt ein alter raus und geht
direkt da rein also ich kann ins zelt
drücken beziehungsweise redstone lampe
dorthin stellen dann habe ich hier so
ein paar blöcke drin die werden dann
direkt da reingepackt das ist auf jeden
fall auch sechs wieder runter scrollen
spielt eine seite voller höhe so kommen
wir nun zu tnt lore die ich auch schon
vorhin angesprochen haben und zwar wird
das durch eine aktivierung china aus
plötzlich auch schon vorhin angesprochen
habe manchester zu fall und zwar werden
schienen und die sich unter ihnen
befinden blöcke zerstörter sind die über
der über dem tier hier sind werden nicht
zerstört das explodiert sofort wenn es
die schiene verlässt also die retter die
aktivierungs dingsbums
und umso schneller die lore da drüber
fährt wenn sie gar ganz langsam darauf
holt dann ist die explosion ganz schwach
tatsächlich also schwach nicht ganz
schwach aber schwächer als sonst relativ
schwach in relation zu den anderen
explosion aber wenn sie relativ schnell
fährt so viel da ungefähr dann kommt das
schon eine große explosion zustande und
was in mir auch aufgefallen ist ein
attest welt das habe ich dahin glaube
ich im dschungel irgendwo gemacht ich
weiß nich seht ihr den krater da ganz
hinten doch nicht nur ich glaube nicht
sagte brille fielmann
und zwar kann das auch explodieren wenn
sie einfach drei blöcke tiefer fällt
oder drei blöcke oder tiefer und die ab
dann gibt es nun eine trichter logo die
funktioniert ähnlich wie ein normaler
trichter die kann allerdings nur geleert
werden wenn sich unter ihr ein trichter
befindet also
ich weiß nicht ob wir dort jetzt
versteht also wenn darunter zum beispiel
die kitze ist dann gehen wir die items
raus und naja kann mit der aktivierung
china deaktiviert beziehungsweise
aktiviert werden und das nimmt halt
items auf die auf der strecke liegen das
heißt wenn ich hier zum beispiel steine
pro a nein ich möchte zum beispiel einen
stein auf die strecke da so schmeißt da
lang so jetzt hat er dort aufgenommen
der stein ist leiterin also ich glaube
da führt also ich sag mal so ich glaube
das versteht ja also ich meine ich hoffe
ihr habt verstanden nicht aussagen
wollte so also ich denke ich dass ihr
blöd seiten ja seid ihr nicht ihr seid
alle die coolsten dann gibt's eines
bonner lore die kriegt man momentan nur
durch inwent inventar hecking also tun
wenn die alters- oder embedded und die
spongebobs auf dem weg wenn sie im woher
fährt habe ich jetzt einmal mehr seine
kiste kissen mainka team gestellt dass
das hat dann einfach ins bonner also wie
gesagt nur durch inventar hecking wir
tun wenn die alte messe cmt
ist das einfachste darin mz könnt ihr
allgemein alle blöcke das habe ich jeden
gestellt blog lore dass es der conan
name da habe ich gesagt dann könne
nämlich mit hilfe von mz einfach alle
blöcke in der lore platzieren aber das
hat nicht nur mit der hilfe von cad bzw
wenn die komplette version 1.5 draußen
ist weil ich spiele ja zurzeit nur in
der provinz version also kommen wir nun
zum spender halo reach ist noch nicht
richtig hinzugefügt wie auch schon bei
der block lore gesagt kommt in der
richtigen version 1.5 und die wird
wahrscheinlich beim überfahren einer
aktivierung schiene ausgelöst also kann
man nur wahrscheinlich sagen weil naja
ihr wisst ist es noch nicht die 1.5 so
richtig draußen sondern dass das hier
nur die promis version sollte man sich
darunter scrollen
so
bekommen wir nutzen evercore zeiten das
ist dieses item hier das sieht so aus
wenn ich das in der hand halte so
bekommt ihr wenn ihr also dass das
netbook pforzheim und das ist das ein
netter konzerts das bekommt ihr wenn ihr
never catch up boards also durch das
abbauen von never quite ärzten wird es
gewonnen und es wird zum herstellen von
diesem tageslicht pension bei denen ich
wohin standort euch das erklärt habe und
redstone komparatoren benötigt die
ganzen crafting rezepte wollte ich euch
jetzt nicht erkennen was wäre dann
wirklich zu lang geworden ich bin ja
jetzt schon fast eine halbe stunde und
ja das kannst du dekorativen blöcken
weiterverarbeitet werden und das ist
dann auch alles dann kommen wir nun zum
männerchor zertz dazu kann man einfach
ein netter gehen hier habe ich ein paar
schon mal hingestellt und dass die da
unten haben sich normal generiert also
die hier sind normal generiert so sieht
das dann ungefähr aus und da sind auch
noch ein paar da hier habe ich mal dahin
gestellt damit ihr die direkt seht also
so können die dann hier einfach
auftreten und ihn braucht die dann ganz
einfach nur abbauen mit einer spitzhacke
dann bekommt ihr diese war diese blöcke
und außerdem bekommt ihr dadurch auch
also ihr bekommt ein wenig die abort
diese sachen dieser kreuzung diese
blöcke sind halt so wie die halt
aussehen
dann gibt es auch noch die quartz schnee
quads blöcke die sehen so aus ihr seht
das unten kreuz blog
das sind drei davon gibt es drei
verschiedene varianten und zwar den
quartz lock das ist der hier das ist der
gemeißelte quatsch block und das ist
diese der säulen quasi block aus diesem
solchen quatsch blöcken habe ich diese
ganzen wege hier gebaut sieht man zwar
sehr schlecht aber okay sie kann schon
über unterscheidet sich jetzt nicht von
reisen sachen und es gibt außerdem noch
eine stufe einer treppe davon die dänen
nur zu dienen nur zu dekorativen zwecken
und die ähneln so marmor von vize ps
kennt ihr wahrscheinlich oder halt
kalkstein oder irgend sowas
und kann jetzt im apple com deswegen
weil ich ein bisschen desorientiert dann
gibt's außerdem jetzt die leser ziege
die gab es vorher aber irgendwie stand
trotzdem dabei deswegen hab ich gedacht
ich erwähnen ist trotzdem mal und zwar
werden die durch schmelzen oder
verbrennen von netter stein beziehen wir
so leicht einige leute kennen besser
unter dem namen netter reck gewonnen und
die können zu jeder ziegel blöcken
verarbeitet werden und außerdem der
artikel stufen oder ziegel sträter
ziegel stufen oder netter artikel
treppen die namen so schrecklichen
netzwerkfähige triple wird siegel stufe
der partikel blog naja dann gibt es nun
auch verbessertes knochen mehr und man
muss zwei bis drei mal drauf klicken um
das letzte wachstumsstadium zu erreichen
über einen benutzen werden dann auch so
grüne partikel angezeigt er ich habe den
baum noch nicht hingestellt weil der es
mir vorhin einfach so gewachsen und zwar
wenn ich koche mir nehme
123 so dann brauche ich immer noch so
ein bisschen bisher wächst weil das ist
jetzt ein scheiß baum natürlich geworden
dann nehme ich mir jetzt hier einfach
mal so ein paar zieht sie sind noch
schon wieder davon gewachsen ist nicht
wahr dann hier soll nämlich paar samen
da 1 2 3 oder 2 also man muss zwei bis
drei mal drauf drücken damit man mir
zudem maximale stufe erreicht hat der
blog ist sterben jetzt schon dass ich
noch die man hier ein bisschen kleiner
anderer seite so dann seht ihr was sie
machen einfach immer komm ich dachte
jetzt einfach so kann man auch mal so
lassen also dass noch mehr wird auch
verbessert ich muss mal wieder runter
scrollen bla bla bla bla es gibt nun
auch verbessert die stufen das heißt 43
doppelpunkt 8 für glatte steinstufen das
sind die hier und 63 doppelpunkt 94
glatte sandstein stufen wenn ihr euch
jetzt fragt herr wird meinte der
betreuung wird dich acht blabla da müsst
ihr einfach /
griffin chat eingeben dann euren namen
bei mir kraft oder halt bei euch keiner
im thaddäus fd.com crafter dann wie
viele jahr haben
erstmal die 43 zum beispiel dann
wie viele hier haben wir zb ein
komplettes tag und nacht dann bekomme
ich jetzt 64 von diesem steinstufen bin
ich jetzt kommt
konnte
39 so dann bekomme ich hier so ein paar
davon also von diesen anderen
steinstufen also ich denke ich hoffe ihr
habt es verstanden ja ich habe gesagt
ich hoffe es gibt nur noch verbesserte
spender und zwar kann können die in alle
sechs richtungen ausgerichtet werden
also oben unten hinten von links rechts
der kann spielern rüstung anlegen die
ein doktor vorstellen das heißt wer
nämlich hier vorstelle und einfach mal
hier wird allerdings drücke so den
schalter
so danach kriegt jetzt zum beispiel die
dings angezogen ist natürlich schon die
sachen dafür da drin haben und dann
krieg ich noch mal drauf dann bekomme
ich das noch mal dann bekomme ich das
also ist auch eine ganz ganz coole
ist halt eine spielerei
so
jetzt kann auch tnt jetzt platzieren
wollte ich jetzt nichts zeigen und weil
es das auch aktivieren kann
naja gleiche sache wie bei der tnt und
aktiviert und ständig mit sich zeigen
weil sonst die welt ist so schön wie sie
jetzt gerade ist kann außerdem auch
knochenmehl auf dem blog vor dem spender
anwenden das ist jetzt schon ein
bisschen gewachsen so ich mach das mal
ganz kurz so
12 302 passiert das mal ganz kurz was
mach ich das ja alles kaputt naja
verzichten ganz kurzen schalter von hier
12 also bei denen sachen braucht man
immer nur zwei sachen glaube ich
mittlerweile ich weiß es nicht na ja
wohl was sagt man dazu gemacht mir egal
ich denke die wahrheit nicht auch noch
so
diese ganzen kleinigkeiten
also das erstmal zudem dispenser also
spender sagt man doch dass pence ab was
die auch noch machen können ist mit
hilfe eines feuerzeugs wenn es da drin
ist feuer entfachen davor dann geht
allerdings die haltbarkeit von dem
fahrzeug runter wollte jetzt aber auch
nicht so meine welt kannst du einpacken
der flippers die wieder rein beziehen
also ein feuerzeug dann drückt auf den
schaltern wie das hier vorne angezündet
es gibt nun auch verbesserten steht man
heute runterscrollen hier so letzte
seite es gibt nur noch verbesserten
schnee und zwar unterschiedliche schnee
hören die schneehöhen die wurden jetzt
endlich implementiert das hier ist nicht
mehr vorhanden ich weiß warum ich hab
das nämlich die so gebaut
wir können dann einfach stehen im
unterricht braucht machen so wie ich
gerade gemacht hat dann kann ich ihn
natürlich so hoch laufen kann man ganz
coole treppen mitmachen und also
implementiert hinzugefügt wenn ihr das
ist nicht so vertraut seit mit dem wort
jede schicht des schnees dropped einen
schneeball das heißt wenn ich die kaputt
mache ich bin creative mord deswegen
seht ihr das nicht aber wenn ich die
kaputt mache dann bekomme ich daraus
einen schneeball die oberste schicht hat
keine kollision spox also wenn ich da
zum beispiel
also kollision spox kann ordnung aber
die oberste schicht hat halt keine
koalitions blog so dass der spieler
etwas im schnee ein gesunkenes ach so ja
doch also koalitions burkhalter das
koalitions box ist halt wenn ich hier
zum beispiel auf dem blog drauf steht
seht ihr meine füße wenn ich hier drin
bin seitdem einen schwarzen füße nicht
weil ich halt im schnee einen sinke
allerdings kann es sein dass der schnee
dann einfach mal verschwindet wenn ich
da ganz lange darauf will ich gehe
deswegen ist ja gerade da auch schon
verschwunden und ja der jetzt auch schon
wieder so als ich denke ihr wisst was
ich meine und
folglich haben dann zum beispiel vier
schneeschichten die haben die größe wie
eine stufe und etwa haben erst bei 5
schneeschichten die gleiche kollision
spox das heißt ich kann auch auf 5
schneeschichten wenn ich dir so hinlegen
ihr seht vier schichten kann ich auch
noch einfach drauf gehen aber ich denke
ja immer so ein bisschen ein also drei
vier schichten sich bis zu drei
schichten ein das heißt wenn ich fünf
schichten habe kann ich ja immer noch
drauf laufen weil es dann so große szene
stufe sind sechs sind allerdings 6 - 10
15 fünf schichten kann ich dann nicht
mehr drauf laufen also ich hoffe ihr
versteht ja so was damit gemeint habe
bzw ich konnte das gut erklären außerdem
gibt es verbessertes leuchtfeuer das
wollte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt zeigen
weil das ist eigentlich relativ
scheißegal
und zwar wurde dort einfach die
reichweite erhöht die erste schicht
macht nun 41 blöcke das von 433 die
zweite schicht 160 werke waren vorher 49
die dritte schicht nach 81 blöcke war
vorher 60 und die vierte schicht nur
noch 124 81 so kommen wir nun zu dem das
verschwindet einfach so das ist
wahrscheinlich wegen der lover so gar
nicht weiter drauf rum laufen ja ich
glaube dass wegen der lava
sonstiges bei den blöcken und items eine
schiene die den spieler und andere mops
aus der luft sobald sie befahren wird
wird bald hinzugefügt also
wenn das zum beispiel eine schiene ist
und ich war mit einer lore darüber dann
wird alles was da drauf ist zum beispiel
rausgeworfen also
zum beispiel eine falle wenn der mob
oder so schien oder im krieg oder so
dahin fährt wieder rausgeworfen das ganz
cool loren können aneinander gehängt
werden also wie gesagt ich kann ich das
alles nicht zeigen jetzt noch nicht
wirklich implementiert wurde die
textsuche der verschlossenen tür wurde
geändert und diese wurde komplett aus
dem spiel entfernt was ich relativ dumm
finde wenn man eine textur ändern und
das dann entfernen dass das relativ 44
für mich und die textur wurde auch
verändert ich habe euch jetzt immer die
jetzige läufer textblöcke zeigt so sieht
zurzeit aus also in der 1.5 das ganze
dann so ein bisschen anders aussehen und
treppen unterbrechen das sprint nicht
mehr das wird allerdings schon
hinzugefügt und zwar kann ich das
einfach so drüber laufen und nun
befinden wir uns auch hier direkt mit
dem anschluss bei den mops ist doch
super dass gerade nacht ist perfekt ich
habe mir nämlich was aufgebaut so den
schnee brauch ich lehre so ich hab mich
schon was aufgebaut ich habe hier ein
skelett und zombies ich brauche jetzt
einfach mal so ein paar skelette so2 und
hier sportlich einfach mal kombis und
dann soll ich hier noch einige sorgen
weil ich möchte euch nun eine sache
zeigen dass ihm jetzt erstmal eine
rüstung anatolien diamant schwert so und
zwar rede ich jetzt erstmal so ein
bisschen habe ich mir jetzt 90 auf der
weg geworfen ich voll rum gl ich bin
noch so blöd dass ich hier meine papier
sozusagen samstag hole ich mir mal kurz
wieder
so ihr seht ihr hier schnellauswahl
leiste längst leg war rechts weg rechts
flexo und dann gehe ich mal ganz kurz in
game mode 0 beziehungsweise nicht jetzt
sondern ich sage euch erst mal ganz gut
so etwas zu und zwar wurden die skelette
verbessert die schließen jetzt aus einer
entfernung von bis zu 15 blöcken zu euch
vorher waren es zehn blöcke und die sind
abhängig vom schwierigkeitsgrad schießen
geht den spieler um einen bock zurück
ich habe jetzt auch einfach von daher
ist das jetzt nicht aber je näher man
kommt desto schneller schießen ja auch
also es kann sein dass die rechte rom
spam in anführungszeichen außerdem
wollen die zombies auch verbessert und
zwar alarmierend die man andere zombies
innerhalb eines bestimmten radius wenn
sich spieler sehen also dass alle ganz
so eine ganze horde auf einen zuläuft
die werden stärker wenn sie leben
verlieren also wenn ich die stark
schlage dann werden die stärker für eine
art adrenalin brennende zombies
übertragen das feuer auch auf den
spieler und die werden nun aggressiv und
komme auf den spieler zu wenn man auf
sie schießt
es hat mir vielleicht damit verbogen
wurde von euch das jetzt hier so
game mode 0 ich geh jetzt mal hier rein
so das geschieht jetzt auf mich so ihr
seht schon das sind das ist eine sehr
sehr lange entfernung unterschied jetzt
auf mich und ich hab noch ungefähr
gesehen wie oft das auch nicht
geschossen hat wenn ich das allerdings
einmal schlagen und mehr an dem skelett
dran bin dann seht ihr schon dass es
sehr viel schneller schießt da schießt
es jetzt schießt es also jetzt schon
dass das sehr viel schneller schießt das
war erstmal das skelett jetzt gehe ich
da noch ganz kurz rüber dass es jetzt
wird mit dem sehen weil die mich eh
schon alle gesehen haben also seht schon
da kommt so eine komplette truppe auf
mich zu und ein zombie wenn er mich
jetzt an gemacht so ein halbes jahr für
das ein bisschen mehr da bleibt man da
drin ihr blöden penner so ich nehme nur
einen zombie jetzt von denen so ihr seht
nun der wird jetzt stärker wenn er mich
angreift also der macht jetzt immer ein
halbes herz und wohin weil das ja nicht
so stark wenn ich nun einfach mal auf
sein
sz 0 mache brennen die zombies natürlich
allerdings wenn ihr mich nicht angreifen
wieso brenne ich nicht eine rüstung
brennig hat nicht ich weiß nicht woran
das liegt aber eigentlich sollten die
brennen weil daraufhin bei mir auch
schon so in dem test welt zumindest was
ich da auch schon gebrannt habe und ja
ich möchte den ganzen sachen müll weil
das man erstmal die sachen für die mobs
beziehungsweise was ich euch zu den mops
noch sagen könnte ist wenn ihr von den
mops
verfolgt werdet dann springen die zwar
auf die schiene aber wenn ihr nicht von
denen verfolgt werden einfach nur in
denen vorbeifahren wie zum beispiel ein
schwein oder ein pc bewohnern oder so
dann ist der fall dass diese schienen
einfach meiden also die laufen da nicht
drüber dann doch zum letzten punkt
letzten kategorie welt generierung und
zwar im netz der gast schon gesehen wird
never kratzen und generiert und in den
verlassenen minen stehen nun keine
tränen mehr soll und güterlok italo
stadtlohn das ist ein guter lohn also
anstatt von normalen anstatt von solchen
ton stehen jetzt einfach solche dazu
brauche ich unterschieden
schön einfach solche güter loren ach die
habe ich hier schon ja also das war so
die letzte neuerung die ich euch noch
sagen wollte wenn es euch gefallen hat
meine lieben freunde dann würde ich mich
definitiv beiden daumen hoch freuen weil
es war echt eine menge arbeit des
sattels insgesamt vier stunden und 14
minuten dran das alles zu planen ich
habe es gleich auch eine fahrstunde von
daher muss ich jetzt auch ganz schnell
weg
schreibt mir einfach in die kommentare
was er am geilsten fand und was ihr euch
eventuell für die 1.6 wünschen allgemein
werde ihr euch das video gefallen hat
und wie schon gesagt gebt eine positive
bewertung haben es euch gefallen hat
weil das zeigt mir ob ich das gezeigt ob
wir mehr von solchen langen
vorstellungen gold und ob es für euch
hilfreich war ich hoffe ich konnte euch
das alles zeigen und dann will ich
einfach sagen facebook führt das er
beschreibt würde mich freuen wenn ihr
das video mit euren freunden teilt uns
einfach weiter sendet oder vielleicht
meurer katze zeigt vielleicht ist ja
auch daran interessiert zu wissen was
einfach hier so hinzugefügt wurde und
dann sehen uns beim nächsten mal schießt
ich bin total leer gesprochene total
ich habe euch lieb